[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
a suspect finally arrested in the cold
case of a nine-year-old's disappearance
the kidnapping that scared parents
across the country
it was so brazen so ruthless but
clearly planned a father accused of
decapitating two of his children
why he appears more concerned with his
own treatment in jail
plus a husband agrees to tell police
where he disposed of his wife's body
our experts take on the controversial
deal and an update in the pike county
massacre case
we bring you inside the hearing for one
of the suspects charged in the ohio
murders
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a california man already in prison for
three murders
has been charged with the disappearance
of a missing nine-year-old girl
david miesha is charged with murdering
and kidnapping michaela garrett
michaela disappeared from a neighborhood
market in 1988
investigators took a fresh look at the
case on its 30th anniversary
a partial palm print found on her
scooter reportedly matched to mich
investigators believe me snatched the
little girl as she went to get her
scooter outside the store
and forced her into his vehicle
she and her friend rode to the local
market to get some candy and sodas
about 10 15 in the morning they were
just kids
carefree certainly unsuspecting of the
danger that lay ahead
michaela's kidnapping devastated her
family
paralyzed them with grief and terrorized
them
with the unknowing of what happened to
michaela
her kidnapped her moved one of the
scooters away from the
store to the back area of the parking
lot
he did so to isolate and be able to grab
michaela when she came to pick up that
scooter
she has never been heard from or seen
again
a fingerprint examiner saw me's name on
the possible suspect
list and painstakingly compared his to
one found on her scooter
that's part of the collaborative effort
the fremont police department
opened up their file and allowed us
access to a case they've been working
obviously the one we mentioned earlier
the double homicide
we also had the the partial palm print
and
do painstaking direct examination at
print
we were able to identify this suspect as
the
perpetrator it wasn't a print that we
could run through the system
it had to be manually compared and so
once the link was made to this as a
possible potential suspect
then a direct comparison to literally
eyesight
had to be made to compare the two prints
well the fremont case um
the crimes that are this man allegedly
committed
were were a little dissimilar from child
abduction
so there were no pointers that led
directly to this suspect other than the
tireless effort of the detectives
investigating it
and they followed through with thousands
of leads
the defendant has a long criminal record
and prosecutors are seeking to enhance
his charges in this case is charged with
murder
of michaela garrett we have also alleged
two special circumstances
the first one is that michaela was
murdered in the course of a kidnapping
and the second special circumstance is
that
david mitch has been convicted of a
previous murder
the complaint also alleges that david
mitch has been convicted of two prior
felony convictions one for assault with
a deadly weapon
in 1982 and one conviction for
for commercial burglary just three
months before
michaela's kidnapping
as the chief said david mitch is
currently in santa rita
a pending trial on a multiple murder
involving two women
he has been she is currently serving
time in state prison
for the murder of another woman in 1989
police then read a statement from the
victim's mother who says she's grateful
her daughter's kidnapper has been
finally identified
i feel as though i am looking for
michaela but now i don't know where
i honestly feel lost in the dark over
the years
i have often wondered whether i really
want to know the truth of what happened
to michaela
i wondered if i would be able to take it
when i received the news
of the kidnapper having been identified
i asked the hard questions of detective
purnell
of what method this man used to kill his
victims and received answers
and they were not easy when i had
doubted whether i would want to know
it always come back to if michaela could
experience it
i could hear it because it's not about
me
it's never been about me about my
feelings
it has always been about michaela
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney mike corbonis along with terry
austin
mike mikayla's remains have still yet to
be found
and the case rests on this whole partial
palm print as a former prosecutor
how strong do you think this case is
these cases
i i have seen in recent times these
cases become much stronger when there's
not a body recovered
because of forensics i always think it's
a great risk though it may be just
the old school in me but it's not an
easy case for a prosecution when there
is no body
terry based on that do you see the
family getting their day in court
or perhaps the defendant pleading out i
mean he's already in jail for another
murder
you know brian it's entirely possible
that the family might still have their
day in court
of course he could always plead out but
i think that if a prisoner is in custody
and he's been identified as a
perpetrator in an older case
and as long as the statute of
limitations hasn't run
he of course can be prosecuted for that
crime the statute hasn't run here
because this is a murder
and so i think that it should be
prosecuted it would give the family
more closure of course we'll keep eyes
on that seeing how
developments progress maybe they find
more information more evidence
that connects niche to the incident at
hand and the death in kidnap of this
young girl
and now to a case you've got to check
out police in pennsylvania need your
help finding a suspect accused of
shooting an officer
algani county police say suspect kobe
lee francis
kicked out a window of the vehicle
during his arrest for violating a
protective order
the officer attempted to remove francis
from the car when he was shot three
times
the officer is currently in the hospital
in stable condition france has fled the
scene
anyone who sees him is asked to call
9-1-1 immediately
still ahead on law and crime daily a
husband accused of murdering his wife
is captured after fleeing across the
country so why are prosecutors striking
a deal with him
but first a father accused of doing the
unthinkable to his children
hear what he has to say after the break
[Music]
welcome back a california father is
accused of decapitating two of his
children
prosecutors in los angeles say maurice
taylor fairly stabbed his 13-year-old
daughter
and 12-year-old son he's also accused of
forcing his two other children
to look at their decapitated bodies and
keep them in their bedroom
for days without food fire rescue
initially responded to a call
of a possible gas leak at the home in
lancaster on december 4th
the fire personnel saw the bodies and
called the sheriff's department
investigators believe the children were
killed five days earlier
taylor appeared in court for his
arraignment on charges of murder and
child
abuse do you understand that
no i was i was not bothered sir i wanted
to defend myself and i never agreed on
counsel
you want to represent yourself yes sir i
was probably under
[Music]
the defendant says he wants to represent
himself he went back to speak with his
attorney and when he returned
said he stands by that decision
there's been several attempts on my life
in jail
and i want to represent myself so i can
have this case go as fast as possible
because if i get sent back to jail today
i'm going to get killed and i have
evidence
that there's a hit on me and that the
police are involved and they've already
tried to kill me
and they keep trying to make me get a
lawyer that's going to delay
things to send me back to jail so i'll
get killed and i don't i don't
appreciate that
and i don't think it's fair that you're
that you're
that this is nothing there's evidence
that they tried to kill me when they
arrested me i literally
had to go to the hospital and they
arrested me when i was fine
i don't want to go back in the police
custody i don't want to do the trial now
i don't want them to
[Music]
[Music]
the judge warned taylor that
representing himself could be against
his best interest
taylor said he's ready to go to trial
now
the jury will decide if i'm innocent or
guilty i say that i'm innocent
i don't need an interim i think that we
should just go through this right now
and decide if i'm innocent or guilty
without an attorney and let the jury
decide isn't that the
constitution well you're summarizing it
pretty well except that it doesn't
happen on the timeline that you
are requesting okay well if i can't send
back to jokes today they're going to
kill me there's been several attempts on
my life i've been to the emergency room
and i wasn't treated properly at the
emergency room so i have to leave early
back with me our attorneys terry austin
and mike corboni terry
the judge said he wouldn't rule on
taylor's request to represent himself
until he gets a mental health evaluation
based on what you've seen there how do
you think that request will turn out
you know i think that was the right
decision by the judge he wants to make
sure that taylor's competent to stand
trial
you know if he is unable to understand
the nature and consequences of the
proceedings and he can't assist
properly in his defense then i think he
won't be
found competent to stand trial and so
you know i think it's the right decision
by the judge and
i think it might very well be that he is
found not to be competent
yeah there's a strong possibility mike
we've had these clients we've all had
these clients speaking in the same way
same manner and you say can you even be
represented
but let's say he is able to repres be
represented he's not he is mentally fit
do you think this is the type of case
that someone should be pro se
he who represents himself has a fool for
a client
i don't think any case anyone should
represent himself
the biggest danger in representing
yourself is that every time you ask a
question the jury's gonna wonder
are you making a statement or how did
you know that you had to be there if you
knew that
very dangerous road to travel down i
think at best in this kind of case
even if the judge says he can't
represent himself he will have someone
seek
second seating him of course an attorney
advising him
and that'll probably be the smart and
the the kind of like the splitting the
baby for lack of a better term
allow him to be pro say but still have a
lawyer there at his side because like
you said there's some really
serious pitfalls that could come up by
representing yourself
thanks thanks mike and terry coming up
on law and crime daily a key suspect in
the massacre of an ohio family appears
in court
plus prosecutors strike a deal with a
murdering husband
but is it worth it to find a woman's
body you decide
[Music]
next
a florida man has pled guilty to
murdering his wife in exchange for
telling police where her body is
gretchen anthony was reported missing in
march after her blue mini cooper was
found in a hospital parking lot in
jupiter florida
her husband david anthony fled a week
later police arrested him across the
country in new mexico
cadaver dogs alerted to areas in the
couple's home and the defendant's nissan
frontier
but they were unable to locate a body
now
anthony is agreeing to plead guilty to
charges of second degree murder
and kidnapping and a deal that includes
a 38-year
sentence within hours of the hearing
investigators
found remains they believe are gretchen
anthony
mike some would say he kidnapped and
murdered someone
and so he should get at least life in
prison but what are your thoughts on the
deal to get 38 years in exchange
for telling authorities where her body
is
i think it was a pretty
smart move by the prosecution we we
talked about earlier about the
difficulty in prosecuting a case
when there's nobody recovered at least
my feelings of it
i think a 38 38-year sentence for a 40
i think he's 44 year-old year old man
is equivalent to the life sentence
there's been studies that show
for every day spent incarcerated for
people that's like two days off your
life expense
expectancy because of those conditions i
think this was
closure it got everybody what they
needed and anything more would have been
nothing more than grandstanding
and it appears they've taken the
consideration of the victims
in into their process of coming to a
decision i think it was the right one
now mice correct he's hitting a lot of
the big words there terry closure and
talking to the family
the family actually supports this
decision
and based on that is it the right move
to let the victims decide
the sentence in exchange for something
like this closure
you know i agree with mike every
situation however
is different the prosecution has to work
with the victim's family
to determine what is best for the
victim's family and
also public interest what i will say
though brian
it's unfortunate that killers know they
have this as
leverage and they often say well i will
help you find the body if i get a lesser
sentence
so to me they are sometimes manipulating
the system
and that i do not like but i think you
have to listen to the family
definitely two very distinct and
possible ways to look at this you
definitely want to
talk to the victim's family in the case
and i think uh
especially when comparing to other cases
not finding the body that's devastating
i'm glad the family found some closure
in that information thanks guys when we
come back
why is it taking so long for justice in
the case of a family massacred in ohio
the court hearing from one of the
suspects just after the break
[Music]
one of the family members accused in the
execution-style murders of another
family
appeared in court law and crime's
angelina levy was in pike county today
and joins us with the latest in the
massacre case
yeah brian you know we expected to hear
arguments today from jake wagner's
attorneys about why they say
ballistics and shoe impression evidence
should not be allowed at trial but that
didn't happen
after all now first off wagner arrived
late to court the prosecutor told us
that someone at the pike county
sheriff's office
actually forgot to pick up wagner from
the jail the judge is still deciding
whether wagner is entitled to a hearing
to dispute the ballistic and shoe
impression evidence the state intends to
present at trial
wagner his parents and older brother are
accused of murdering eight members of
the rodent and gilly families in april
of 2016. the state says the motive was a
custody dispute
over a daughter that wagner shared with
hannah rhoden prosecutors say wagner
owned a gun
at one time that fired the same
ammunition found at the crime scenes and
on his property
they also contend that shoes that
wagner's mother bought at walmart for
him and his brother matched shoe prints
found in blood at the crime scenes
just for the record and i know that
we've made our
opinion clear both in written motion and
in chambers but specifically as it
pertains to
47 and 48 the space position is that
they are not entitled to a theory
on facilities matters so that's you know
i just wanted to
take that position
now wagner's attorneys have called that
ballistic and shoe impression
evidence junk science meanwhile they are
also
asking that one of the special
prosecutors on the case be removed by
the judge
andy wilson is a former elected county
prosecutor who now
works for ohio governor mike dewine as a
policy advisor
dewine was the attorney general at the
time of the rhoden murders and oversaw
the investigation
wagner says because wilson is involved
in policy matters with the state public
defender's office
that means he has a conflict of interest
but wilson says he has actually removed
himself
from those issues i would wonder
whether mr wilson retains a
responsibility or at least an
expectation that
he personally would keep the governor
updated
on all of these proceedings
because you know ultimately the governor
will have that final authority as we
described in our original motion
the governor has not intervened in my
presentation in this case in any way
before and there is no reporting duty
for me with respect to my
obligation to this case the only uh
the only communication i've had with the
governor really about the case
is potential trial dates so that we can
plan for
how that affects my role as a in the
policy side of the governor's home
and judge randy gearing is expected to
rule on that motion
at a later date and hopefully sometime
soon meanwhile also today
jake wagner waived his right to a speedy
trial until
october 1st of 2021
mr wagner do you feel that you've had an
adequate opportunity to discuss your
right of speeding trial with your
attorneys here
yes sir and you feel that you understand
your life speedy trial
yes and of course you know the court did
not afford you to speedy trial and the
charges would have to be dismissed and
could not later be
brought you'll also understand that yes
now a trial date is expected to be set
sometime next week along with
a future motion hearing date we're
hearing the talk is they're shooting for
an
august trial date the prosecution is
insisting on trying jake wagner first
brian thanks internet my panel is back
with me for legal analysis on this
hearing
terry defense is arguing junk science
and waiving speedy rights
what do you make of this appearance by
the defense
you know i don't think that this is junk
science i think that
these you know evidence the ballistics
the shoe prints
i think all of that makes sense it's
critical pieces of evidence
and as long as it was obtained properly
i think it's
extremely relevant so i'm a little bit
surprised
that they are really questioning that
this should be admitted you know and as
for the speedy trial
i'm always wondering why defendants are
willing to
do that if they are sitting in jail
which this defendant
is but it happens more often than not
actually
all right mike maybe you can help us
answer that question in terms of
strategy
this person is already in what and why
are they waiving speedy trial rights
well there's a
there's usually a couple reasons number
one is speedy trial has many exceptions
and we're quite frankly in a pandemic
which has caused
a lot of difficulty in representing a
client properly
which brings me to the second reason why
i would tell a client to waive speedy
trial is
this seems like a complicated case
there's multiple defendants
there was a lot of investigation it is
going to take a lot of time to prepare
your defense to this case
so sometimes i'll tell the client be
careful what you wish for you may get it
you may get your speedy trial but we're
going to be prepared to protect you
the best way we can alright so maybe
this is about going through some
voluminous or very complicated sources
of information
again this is a multi-defendant case
maybe this is a wise move by defense
maybe not we'll figure it out
what about you terry you said you kind
of question it does that make sense as
to why they might have waived speedy
trial rights
yeah i think that does make sense of
course he's always going to make sense
here because
you know there are so many defendants
thank you for joining us here at long
crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you